I'm Nation time oh yeah I'm so sorry
guys come on ese everyone I know okay I
know it's been forever I know I know
I've been busy
now really well here I am okay listen
let's just jump into it guys this just
like old times
for real I'm excited to finally be
playing it's just that I've been bait I
haven't but yeah you know what I have
been busy all right where were we
all right we're supposed to go in there
let's start off with a loading screen
yeah so how are how have you been doing
still the same stale comments good job
Felix okay so I remember this place we
don't have much oil left at all this is
really scary
what is this it's very dark and very
loud and I know you can jump into the
the bro okay so hey look at that you
stinky alright so so far we're doing
good no one's died is just tiny little
bit of blood I know in one of these
doors that little sneaky sneaky sneaker
will show up I know it I remember it
okay
boiled [ __ ] oh there's not about torch
what is this awesome we got old apart oh
that is some monster [ __ ] oh there is Oh
God
[ __ ] what have we got
drill party huh god I forgot I forgot no
no no I can't do this now no no no no no
no no no I'm fine
back
now
[Applause]
fine idiot I forgot about the stupid
lamp
I don't think it would see me nobody got
supervision I know he's got weird ice I
forgot how good I am at the game you see
that did you see that barrel blockage
honestly let's talk about it okay
all right bro we're gonna do that again
bro and you're not gonna hurt me okay
you're not gonna hurt me cuz I'm not oh
I have 13 ok let's start using this
that's right let's lit this place up
make it nice and cozy nope we're fine
you actually saved my life thank you I
wonder what they did problem yeah hello
they won't budge I'll use the No
it's anyone down there ah shoot
what does that mean find a way to start
the engine find the key the rocket here
it is okay all right so we need to find
all explosives I remember this isn't
that right bear roll just open dude just
open man okay maybe we miss something
I know you can progress here I have a
guy instrument yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah no God we're going deep down
hello Oh God the ambience is so dank
hello okay stop crying
no you make the drill I remember that
you make hello I know there's one door
there's one god-forsaken door all right
we're cool
shut up Daniel okay we got a drill part
and now BAM no okay okay all right
I've done this before it should not be
this hard now I'm just wasting them okay
okay that's right ah Jesus Christ
everything is just out to scare me it's
got to be something else
get the rill we need that Oh No well
then I don't know shush
listen life is sorry it's not my fault
we're all gonna die I just don't want to
die like this
not like this man hello
all right where is it there you are
found you shush I'm coming for you lady
now we can find ya
damn so good games figure it out all by
myself now we will suck oh yeah oh wait
I forgot I forgot where do I put this
oh yeah so epic so epic so now we have a
filled pipe with explosive
we're cool you're not there bro yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
told you I told you you can do this
without going in and there what is in
here hello
ooh a note let reading time regarding
explicit mixture we already sold it
well anyway Alexander I have prepared
explosive you need for clearing the
flood drain I can't stress enough how
important it is that the mixture is
handled with care please try to tell
your featherbrained servants this before
you go ahead with your plans let's try
to tell your featherbrained servants
that this before you go ahead there
liquid are not the liquids are not
themselves explosive and should be kept
separated to avoid further mishaps I've
arranged two large bats in the next room
for the ingredients all you need to do
is mix the liquids and you are ready to
go
Agrippa a grouper sounds like a rapper
name doesn't it kind of like it
well someone has been pooping bricks am
i right
I like how I said pooping instead of
[ __ ] just in case
alright let's let's be done with this
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no wait I know
don't waste the line Jan I know I know
guys I know it's not official okay where
was it was it here yeah yeah yeah this
is why we need the rock
conveniently-placed Rock you know what
I'm gonna do with the barrel that would
be at me okay you place it here you
place it here oh my god just I know
you're supposed to place it what am I
missing
oh it's filled with them ah why didn't
you tell me my god I'm supposed to do
everything stupid it's gotta be here
it's gotta be now it's roll ready hole
so it's dripping there so we place it
there it's already been collecting where
they're freaking oh oh listen it's dark
okay I don't see everything yeah yeah
okay now Oh God
okay Oh God
oh this is not good
cap in the corner Avenue car
I'm using cover for this one voice oh
god you go deeper in here remember now
hey don't do it PewDiePie I know we have
a lot of differences but we can really
make it together never goodbye
completely unaffected I made it alive
beauty pie okay there was something I
had it oh oh [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] that was
funny
the girl was been in here the soul of
2012 beauty pie trapped
alright we're fine we're fine god damn
it oh god we're not fine okay it's fine
okay this is where the fun begins for
not me what did they do you know the
questions alright let's lit here just so
we know okay god damn it's dark
oh god that's the door that's the door
that's the door
I never foot but oh [ __ ] oh is this
potatoes they look like him
I ain't touching that door oh okay I
have a plan I have a plane
I have a plane brush okay we're working
together now after all these years
we're working together it's working out
group [ __ ] oh god is so dark okay and
now to throw no [ __ ] bread at his
face
others girl there yeah no no no god damn
it I forgot still scares me No
oh god I remember this - oh definit I
don't know
Oh God okay okay what am i ah
that why did I do that okay alright okie
dokie
oh god oh god oh god okay no okay this
is Jay let's hide god damn
my heart hurts it hurts
I'm too old guys okay
I think he's left the thing is now we
have to get out so brilliant the way
they designed this you go in this awful
place and then you got to make it out I
think we have all of them this is truly
awful I don't even see anything I
remember seeing him for the very first
time here you can see and I've never
seen him before
and it scared me so much
we're broke whoa whoa whoa
knew it I [ __ ] the problem is I have
to get out of here and I can't I can't
see anything
oh there is okay
no go No
he's coming back I can't deal with this
he's gay is he gonna come back the same
way or how did anyone play this game
is he not coming her
please don't be here
I can't see anything okay
nice and slow god damnit what is he
doing
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh oh look
scary movies I have not played many
scary games either way this is by far
the most scary experience of my life
no doubt about that
I can't see anything where am I
no that's impossible where
that's impossible
where where
tell me [ __ ] where oh god I made a
sound
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
Oh God take the barrel
Jesus Christ give me a break how did
anyone play this game I'm glad that's
over
I'm really glad that's over oh look at
you don't forget the bag Daniel
I won't ever there is no shame in using
a parasol in the desert as it happens
it's imperative to your survival but it
looks ridiculous the shade would hurt
much less and die I assure you
nothing hurts more than this paint that
is sexy I'm strangely aroused oh yeah oh
no oh look at this this place used to be
nice guys what happened all right
excuse me so now we have the flow and
all the cycle rods we had the machine
room key we gotta go to that machine
room key good job good job you wasted
all your oil oh yeah I know I know that
my god that was awful I never want to do
that again if I get the idea to play
this game in eight years just just say
no this is the Machine room I believe
yeah let's just jump into it normally I
would just cut it there cuz I don't feel
like playing anymore I just for the sake
that it's too heavy and I need a break
but I do know that the machine room is
mainly puzzles if I remember correctly
so maybe this could be a nice life 18:39
today i went to the university looking
for answers i was able to sneak into
Herbert's office and pick up an address
book along with some relevant textbooks
professor Taylor at the Faculty of
history was very helpful and I managed
to approach the subject of the orbs the
most interesting aspect was the
prevalent trace they had left in our
culture the mythic orbs may in fact have
inspired the globus crucita which so
many royal regalia holds to this day in
ancient times the orbs were held by
priests as a symbol of the Sun and its
power as I was leaving I overheard a
disturbing conversation so William Smith
that geologist was killed last night
less than a fortnight had passed since
I'd asked me for tonight
Gordon I can't help feeling responsible
some help what did you do to it
fortnight that looks that big so we got
a fixed elevator that's why we're here
and we just got some chair info I really
need I forgot a confusing these places I
don't remember this at all
the thing is like I know I'm safe here
because I remember but back in the day
when you did this it was kind of like oh
my god is anything gonna happen you
never felt safe you never really knew
like and solving puzzles when you don't
know it's kind of Uri to say the least
although it should be obvious that
you're safe here and then when I put
them to place the monster will yeah and
all the lights will go out and I will
piss my panties as usual even though I'm
ready for it it still scares me oh we
haven't seen the other amnesia monster
yet
I just remembered Oh God 14th of July
1830 Millie I've read every book I can
find on the subject while rich in legend
and hearsay my knowledge is lack for the
insight I crave
I've sent letters to many in Herbert's
address book and received answers of
varying importance today I got one which
differed greatly from the others from a
baron in prussia he said nothing about
the quaint stories of priests in
underground temples he didn't even
mention them he simply wrote I know I
can protect you come to brennenburg
castle signed Alexander yeah it seems
like a good yeah protect me from what is
someone after me I looked up brennenburg
and traced it to the Prussian woods near
the Baltic Sea while being the least
informative letter I've received it
causes me greatest distress and interest
as I write my thoughts are drawn to my
nightmares in which her most disturbing
sound calls to me a sound defying
description a voice from the void the
last few weeks have been awful
with so many sleepless nights dreading a
repeat of those horrid dreams
tomorrow I shall visit my physician dr.
Tate and hope that he can provide me
with sedatives to help me sleep well we
know dr. Tate did do know nothing okay
um wait I came from it's very dark
it's a cartwheel well there's clearly
one more note so what would that be then
if only I had a little bit more
I can't where did it go
I have lights on me as well so it's
super hard to see I know it's
frustrating it's frustrating for me too
where did it freaking go oh there's
something in here
oh here's the cold and stuff I remember
oh that's what you're supposed to put in
maybe if you can give me just like a
tiny bit just a tiny bit of oil I don't
think that's too much to ask
thank-oo my god oh my god my prayers
have been answered
okay so you grab these I'm thinking yeah
there's the thing
I think like let's do three that's the
magic number in video games uno dos look
that was even oh my god
well he's still impossible to see
be quiet game I'm solving puzzles look
what I say yeah it's burning time now
this will start working and now we place
the rods Oh cogwheels oh we need these
look at that I have to find the parts
missing cogwheels that's a cogwheel so
we saw one earlier so we just need to
find one more and let's check if it's
here god damn I'm smart I'm like IQ 5550
there you are
alright we'll throw you down and then
we'll find the last one it's gotta be
somewhere
it's got to be got to be where are you
you're stinky you're stinky cogwheel I
don't like you must be in the beginning
it must be him what the Frick is that
where's the last cog wheel
of God is it gonna you're gonna do me
like this game really there you are
that's a good color plots I love you
wow what an original sentence and learn
your surrender written I don't think
this is the fastest way to do it but
it's the motion come on okay here we go
what do you mean it then fate are you
kidding me there you go there you go ha
ha there you go oh look at that Jordan
there you go what do you mean more work
but no the game continues what else
[ __ ] work do you need what do you
mean what do you mean okay it's those
levers up there I know wait
it's a machine part made of wooden metal
okay
okay yeah we have them eight up and
seven down okay
all right this is epic so where do I put
the rods that's what she said oh yeah oh
yeah dab on this video right now let's
not waste my [ __ ] line let's do that
what do you put the rods you gotta put
the rod there the IB so Trinity Trinity
goes mmm let's see oh wow blow though
well ooh or oh well I must be some kind
of genius Wow incredible so smart my
abilities of sub puzzles is inspiring I
know I know
why was I what was I doing was it ate up
a-town yeah okay math everybody okay
let's see you oh okay let's see a five
five all right no that isn't working
four five six seven eight five wait what
are you doing
no one asked you oh god goddamn it
I thought I had it all right let's start
on say it's fine it's fine it's fine
I'm good at solving puzzles shut up okay
so basically basically okay basically
let's see here okay
one of these it must be up and one of
them must be down otherwise is an epic
troll three four five six seven eight
four I mean six seven eight every guy I
did it or do they all have to be pulled
god damn god damn yeah oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah
sold it before you would have solved it
get trolled lib turns oh yeah mmm that
feels good to be a gangster oh gee let's
break getting doodies
don't even care I care ah now now you
taking two steps too far
no stop repairing front of me okay
Oh ray okey-dokey pokey smokey all right
so we've been through a lot today that
was a good episode I I want to go to the
elevator because that's where the magic
happens we're gonna go down and we're
gonna Oh God in the next episode thank
you guys for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed leave a thumbs up if you did
subscribe and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye